before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
it helps to make the right entrance
thank you
hey there folks
feel like doing another doctor who lists
and this is one that honestly
I should have done a long time before
this because
almost four years ago now
like when I was still wearing the flat
cap I did a video on what I thought were
the best exits for companions on modern
era Doctor Who
I never talked about their best
introductions the best debuts what
companion made the best first impression
so I'm gonna make up for that
now let me clarify what I mean by
companion for this because I tend to use
a slightly different definition
depending on the nature of the video so
in this instance we are talking about
anyone where the actor ever had their
name appear in the opening credits but
we are not counting one-off companions
in specials
that's the one thing that we're not
doing so discounting that that's our
criteria so we've got a fair few of
these to get through and also before I
get started let me note this is by no
means an indication of who I think is
actually the best companion some
companions I don't really like gave
great initial Impressions some
companions who I love did not make
particularly good initial Impressions
this has got to be all over the place
and it's also even not strictly speaking
a judgment on the story they were
introduced in but more about how they
come across as a character when they are
first introduced that's what I'm
focusing on here let's do it
number 16.
Mickey
and no he's not this slow because of any
personal feelings I might have about
Noel Clark he has this low because
honestly who the heck had a positive
notice of Mickey and his first
appearance I actually just the companion
I do like Mickey as a character but when
he was first introduced well first of
all there's the thing that you wouldn't
have guessed he would eventually become
at least briefly a companion and travel
with the doctor but more than that he's
irritating and he's a side note his
endangerment is played for laughs and
it's just not great I didn't come away
at any point thinking boy hope we get
more of that character I was actually
kind of thinking boy they really don't
know how to make any good use of that
character can we not have him again now
my opinion did change when she's once he
started showing up more but yeah initial
impression on Mickey was
was pretty bad
it was about the worst
number 15.
nardol coming in only
slightly ahead of Mickey like it's real
real close and if you ask me on a
different day I might even swap them but
again I really like Nardo I actually
think he is severely underappreciated as
a companion just as a character unto
himself but also as part of the dynamic
with Bill and the 12th doctor I actually
like him a lot
his introduction was not good though
because his introduction was in the
husbands of river song as
the comedic side character and you could
argue he remained primarily a comedic
side character even as he became a
companion and was traveling with the
doctor but the thing is
that was all he was here and he was a
shrieking comedic side character they
didn't bother to write a decent
character and they just expected Matt
Lucas to make the delivery entertaining
and he's trying bless him but you need
an actual character for him to build off
of this in and of itself no
number 14.
Clara
now I need to be real specific about
this what I'm counting as Clara's
introduction is the introduction of the
version of Clara that actually travels
with the companion so we are not
counting Oswin we are not counting the
governess both of whom make much better
First Impressions than the actual Clara
who traveled with the Doctor Who
basically comes off as a blank slate
I will never stop being annoyed at
Moffett for this because he wrote two
earlier versions of Clara that I felt
like I got a sense of who they are and a
sense of their characterization almost
immediately and there was so much
injected into them that really made me
interested in them and made me kind of
go oh I wish that they were sticking
around and then the version of Clara
that actually traveled with us he just
didn't bother to do anything
I think he kind of assumed or hoped that
people would just take what they'd seen
in the other versions of Clara and
project it as characterization onto this
version
unfortunately that only makes sense in
hindsight because we didn't know why
there were multiple versions of Clara we
didn't know that they that these other
versions were splintered off and
variants of this one core main one
re-watching it works slightly better if
you know that but we didn't know that
initially we didn't know what the hell
was going on as far as we were concerned
this is a whole new person that you did
not bother to characterize at all she
has very little personality very little
brought across in terms of her hopes her
dreams her goals she's just there to
Banter a little bit and run around it's
a really bad first impression and made
all the worse
because we know Jenna Coleman can nail
the first impression we saw her do it
twice already and then this
ah
number 13.
wealth this was basically on the list
just to prove that I'm not strictly just
biased in terms of I'm putting ones I
don't like lower or the ones that I do
like higher because Wolf's one of my
favorite companions I absolutely adore
wealth
but
his initial uh intro is really just a
couple of gags you know it's it's him
Manning the uh the little newsstand and
yelling at the at the Titanic Oh you
aliens but it's cute it's sweet it's not
anything that I thought I want to see
more of him now when he did come back
I'm like oh this is great but I was not
left wanting more and I certainly wasn't
left going oh I hope he actually travels
with the doctor now what he did it was
amazing but since nothing about his
first impression really left me with a
desire for more of that character or
ever thinking that there would be a
reason to want him around
it's just kind of a oh okay
well that's a thing
numbers 12 and 11.
Ryan and Graham
so uh I tried to separate them out but
honestly
I'm just gonna lump them together
because I can't justify putting one
slightly over the other even though it's
like it's not like they never have
separate scenes from each other it's not
like I never got a little bit of a sense
of the difference between the two or
anything like that it's just they always
really felt like a package deal and I
can't really think of why one would go
over the other so here they are and the
thing is there really just isn't much
there aside from the uh performance
Chemistry Between the actors which is
decent
it's pretty solid the thing is
ultimately they both have better
performance chemistry with Grace so the
first impression that they left me with
went down as soon as she died because
I'm like I actually would have rather
had her and the Tardis and we've got
YouTube instead
all right it's not bad so to say but not
not something that left me going ooh
can't wait for more Journeys with these
folks
number ten
yes Yasmine Khan just slightly edges out
Ryan and Graham because I just feel like
while honestly series 11 does not take
proper advantage of what
characterization she is given she's a
little bit better characterized in this
first appearance than they are now you
could certainly argue that either one of
them or I guess more likely Graham has a
bit more charismatic personality up by a
value of the performer but in terms of
characterization and get a sense of who
she is and getting a sense of why she
might choose to continue traveling with
the doctor I mean granted at the end of
that first episode all three of them
aren't planning to keep traveling but I
kind of get the impression from her
right off that if the doctor had not
accidentally just beaten them all out
into space and just said do you want to
travel with me she would have been the
one that went yes immediately and Graham
and Ryan like it would have been well
maybe maybe not but she absolutely would
have and I got enough of a sense of her
character in that first appearance to
feel comfortable saying that that says a
little something
not a lot but little
number nine
[Music]
Donna
this this one hurts for how low it is
but look
within the scope of her full character
Arc and let me keep in mind I depending
on when you watch this like bear in mind
that that time of recording and release
the specials with her returning are not
out so how that impacts her Arc and my
thoughts on it I don't know but within
her Standard time within the TARDIS
and how her character art goes I totally
get why she starts out the way she does
why she starts out this abrasive this
loud this frankly
irritating and unlikable
because she is irritating I didn't like
her
now again I understand the value of that
over the course of her Arc it's a bit
like how Luke Skywalker's real whiny
when you start out you don't see him in
me that boy I want to stay around and
find out more about your adventures like
no but he also changes and grows and
becomes more interesting and Donna has a
much better Arc than Luke Skywalker so I
don't even know why he made that
comparison but it did mean that her
first impression is real grading and
even after falling in love with her
going back and trying to watch Runaway
Bride
it's it's it's rough it's painful if I'm
being honest
it's it's aspects of her that I like but
are just dialed up so much they become
irritating and the balance hits much
better once she is trapped once she's
actually traveling with 10 and then she
just becomes a more interesting more
empathetic more fascinating character as
it goes but yeah that did mean we had to
start from a rough place and we did
number eight
[Music]
Rory
perfectly serviceable first introduction
it's just that you don't really notice
him so much because he's to the sideline
and we're mainly dealing with Amy now
arguably that was also kind of the case
with Mickey so you might be wondering
why Rory is so much higher on the list
than Mickey is well
largely because we actually get a proper
sense of Rory's Dynamic with Amy and why
maybe they're kind of good together and
we also we may not have known it at the
time not knowing that he was going to be
traveling with them but we get an early
Taste of his Dynamic with the doctor of
what that'll be like and I like their
Dynamic I like the dynamic of all three
of them but I also like the dynamic
between the doctor and Rory Mickey
his first impression really gives no
indication of any of the decent stuff
that's going to come later from him Rory
does at least have that going for him
again he's deeply overshadowed by
everything else going on in 11th hour
and that's not even really a criticism
of all the stuff going on in 11th hour
out of all the things that needed to be
introduced and established and laid uh
and laid out for an audience whether
they were new or returning given this
new era like he got as much attention as
he should have had but it does mean that
as far as first impressions as a
character go he's just
yeah bat in the middle
number seven
[Music]
bill
I like Bill a lot
I actually
I even more than Nardo I think Bill is
an underappreciated companion I think
Bill's fantastic absolutely adore her
Dynamic with Capaldi I adore her
inquisitive nature and her enthusiasm
she reminds me more than a little bit of
Ace and Ace is one of the best
companions from classic
and she has a really good intro here
and there's an extra layer in this intro
because oftentimes the introduction of
the companion is laying out what it is
about them that is going to draw the
doctor to them and make the doctor want
to travel with them by the end of the
episode
the thing is the doctor's already kind
of drawn to her at the start technically
before the start of this thing at all
because he talks about I've seen you in
my class well most people when they
don't understand something they've
thrown you
smile
and I like that he's already intrigued
by her and he's already thinking there's
something to work with here and it just
establishes their Dynamic and their
banter and their chemistry really well
I'm not sure it does all that much to
establish a ton about Bill in terms of a
character in her own right but it does a
great job establishing the dynamic that
is going to be the status quo moving
forward for them as a traveling
companion couple and I think it does
that exceptionally well so here it is
number six
[Music]
Stan
at time of recording I've only fairly
recently re-watched Halloween apocalypse
and
I don't have a ton of good things to say
about it but you know what
Dan is well introduced he's actually
very thoroughly characterized right from
his first introduction where we see him
talking about Liverpool you can clearly
see how much passion he has for this
town and for his home and then you get a
sense of his Dynamic with other people
as he has his interactions with die and
then later at the uh at the food pantry
and you also get the sense of like he
wants to help and he's more than happy
to help others but he's really bad at
accepting help like forget asking for
help he won't even accept it when
offered when frankly he could use it and
then there's just the inherent Charisma
brought about by the actor it makes him
lovable as he is just kind of
overwhelmed by what's going on but not
in a not in a freaking out way which is
never really that interesting but just
in a what the heck
what the heck is going on kind of way
which is like just the right amount of
flummoxed for me I think in terms of who
Dan is as a character and how thoroughly
he is introduced and how well
characterized and how many sort of
Shades and elements of him we get
introduced in a pretty small amount of
time
it's a really well handled intro
it's one of the only well-handled things
in that episode but hey credit where
credit's due
number five
Rose
I am not nearly as enamored of rose as a
lot of fans especially fans my age
but
her introductory episode starts with her
rather than starting with the doctor
and um it works we get a sense of who
she is we get a sense of the on WE of
her life we get a sense of her lack of
fulfillment and then we get a sense of
her being pulled
towards the questions
towards the danger towards the adventure
and we get to experience the doctor
initially very much through her eyes and
so in this first episode we actually get
to know her
better than we get to know the doctor
and honestly if somebody else wanted to
put her introduction
towards the top
I wouldn't necessarily say they're wrong
part of it comes down to personal
preference Rose is not my favorite
companion so while I think she is very
well characterized I'm not a huge fan of
rose as a character but
again credit where credit's due
they establish exactly what they needed
to to make her work and make you care
about her
even before you know what the heck is
going on with the doctor
it's really good
number four
Jack again not gonna talk about the
actor but actually first of all let me
say these last four I could have
reordered like these last four were
really tough to come up with in order
for but number four is going to be Jack
because first of all
it's an amazing two-parter the empty
child and the doctor dances are some of
my favorite episodes they are while they
are my favorite episodes of the first
series and he is just really well
introduced as Charming Suave thinks he's
in control gets flustered and annoyed
when he realizes he's not a little bit
dashing a little bit dangerous
heavily flirty
this is who Jack is
it lays it out very clearly and in a way
that he could have stayed in this
episode he could have not continued to
appear not travel with the doctor not
come back at later times
but the reason it works that he does is
because his intro was this good
you really do get the sense of what he
adds to the dynamic what he brings that
eccleston's doctor especially doesn't
have this sense of more swashbuckling
adventure and that's not a deficit or an
eccleston's part that he doesn't have
that but it brings an extra Dynamic to
the group and
whatever you think about John Barrowman
I've got my thoughts
dude's really Charming dudes really
charismatic and that is effectively what
this character needed at its heart and
it's there
and it's there from the outset he is
magnetic he's Charming
it's really hard not to fall in love
with them
number three
Martha
Martha Jones
first of all under appreciated companion
second of all really unappreciated intro
this is a scientifically precisely
calculated introduction for her as a
companion for us to
get a sense of her as a person as a
person studying to be a doctor in terms
of the things that Intrigue her and how
the doctor is drawn to her because she
asks the right questions
so kind of like how bill was intrigued
by the right things but didn't
necessarily know the most appropriate
question to ask which was sometimes film
because the doctrine was fun in its own
way but Martha does know the right
questions to ask she doesn't know the
answers yet but she wants them
and therefore the doctor gets drawn to
her and a bit like Rose's introductory
episode we spend actually I think a
little more time with her than with the
doctor this is really focused on getting
you to know her sell you who she is why
she's interesting why she's admirable
why she's fun
and it does it it just does it is
phenomenally effective at introducing
her as a character and her Dynamic with
tenant
just really good
number two
[Music]
Amy
I like I'm seriously often just in awe
of the 11th Hour as an episode doing
everything that it does and doing it so
well and I love the way that this is
handled her introduction to the doctor
so you get a sense of why she has this
awe of him but at the same time because
he left her there for years this is
important why did you say six months why
did you say 5
.
she's kind of fed up with his nonsense
at the same time as she is absolutely
drawn to him and fascinated by him and
pulled to him but she's also like don't
mess with me dude you've you've ticked
me off once before already and just the
tiny moments with her interactions with
other people like
she's a kissogram but like some guy is
trying to get to his car and she's kind
of blocking his way and he just and she
just tells him in a bit now go and have
coffee
right and he knows her he's like Amy I
and she just commands him away that's
who she is in this town she just runs
This Town by sheer force of personality
and you see that again with Rory and the
way that he responds being around her
her interactions with not just the
doctor but everyone else that she says
hi to or interacts with it all you get a
full sense of who she is as a person who
she is to these other people who she is
in this town that she is just so many
things orbit around her because she is
so charismatic
of course everybody like has a sense of
what their place is with her and they
know it
and she knows it and it's really well
established it's really fun
and number one
[Music]
River Song whatever you think about what
happened with River's story about its
highs its lows its middles
her introduction
was brilliant
the way in which
she is able to carry the weight of the
excitement of seeing the doctor again
the pain
and realizing he doesn't recognize her
the tragedy of the sacrifice that she
makes the flippant
chemistry that she has with him even
though this version of him doesn't know
her she's still slipping into that very
clearly for her very comfortable Dynamic
that he doesn't know yet we're all gonna
die right here and you're just
squabbling like an old married couple
this is just an amazing introduction to
a character
to bring her in and she knows what's
going on but he doesn't and to see how
that impacts her
because it's not just a matter of he
doesn't know oh she knows more than him
like no the fact that he doesn't know
has a clear effect on her
in the effect that it has
tells you a lot about her
and so much about how she carries
herself how she is commanding very
clearly even though she's not
technically in charge of the expedition
and all these other things it's all
there
she is a complete package and you get a
sense of who she is going to be as a
companion just within this one story
just within this two-parter even though
she doesn't actually travel with this
doctor in it and she never travels with
this specific doctor not that we see
it's
phenomenally well balanced this is a
Razor's Edge of
efficient intriguing
fun
tragic
this is just brilliant
and again I know some people complain
about River partly because of like oh
it's the it's the female character that
Moffett always writes and I I get that
criticism and I'm not going to argue
against it but one I happen to kind of
like that uh female character archetype
and two structurally I would still argue
this is really smart and really well
portrayed
so that's my number one what do you
think how would you rank this and how
wrong do you think I am whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon is
what pays the bills and enables me to do
this as my living and also if you
support me there you get early access to
the videos you get to look at the docket
a month early you get to vote in polls
etc etc
etc but uh don't worry too much about it
because what I really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
no matter how you come into the story
remember that you are the council and
I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look fulla to rock the thing
that goes doink in the anime Ruth Oliver
B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]
oh